wesley saw that just comes off a draw
against levonoronyan wesley you seem to
have good prep that your opponent played
one more move than you did
no i mean
i wanted to turn but leave one
apparently unless also this position
with the white pieces
and he knows that you're very well so i
he played this catalan with c5
a few times i played regularly and you
played this regularly as well
yeah i played against england it's a
very solid line and last night i was
looking at several lines i could try
uh but
basically if black knows the theory
which i assume the bond mostly knows
then he equalizes
pretty much i was looking for an
interesting way that's why i came up
with rupex d4 on move 13. yes but it's
not we shot the main line i mean
it doesn't look very nice
objectively because the queen side pawn
seemed weak
but i assume that one would be well
prepared against he takes d4 i played c4
on 12 against him in
romain no where is it in poland in
poland yes yeah but uh didn't get much
so
the point of this line i guess is to
provoke black to play e4 on mobile 14
e5 rook d1 but it's very accurate i
think it's the best move and the one
bleeds it out because he even blitzed it
up to h6 but once you play knight c4 he
seemed a little bit stuck what was going
on through both of your minds
yeah because the main line is 38 first
on move 16. ah rotate in this position
yeah and then after g4 h6 and then b1 uh
this move order yeah actually one told
me that he prepared this line after the
game but he makes it up so that his
preparation was through b1 b6
knight c6 through b7 95 through b7
knight d3 knight e4 and claim black
equalizers so
it's fascinating yeah the problem with
this end game
yeah that you either go for the main
lines or right you try something new but
then black has multiple ways to try and
hold a very decent position but i want a
pawn here i thought i had some chances i
played bishop f5 yes
yeah i thought i was a pawn up but it's
i spent a lot of time i couldn't find
way to make progress like i was going to
play g4 first
instead of what sorry inside knight d3
uh g4 right away yes bishop c2 bishop c2
rook d2 and then he can play bishop h7
let's see knight d3 bishop b6
bishop b2 knight e4 and black probably
just
no problems at all so
a lot of activity for black compensation
for the pawn yeah yeah
no problems so in the game
i thought i was consolidating i was
happy after king f1 yes
but lack of several chances basically if
i get bishop b to rook ac1 and then c4
and i have very good chances to win
but lebron played bishop e4 and then i
couldn't
refine me because he's starting to take
on g2 and then rokito
and i don't want to take on e4 and
activate this knight
but i didn't really see any option like
i could play bishop f3 here yes
and then he can probably take take
and then i don't know just rook c8 or
something
again with compensation yeah if my feet
won
only on b3 then i would be winning again
well that's a big idea
yeah but the problem like i was talking
about these lines the c3 pawn is always
weak in many lines so so you decided to
give the pawn back and after that it
just seemed like you didn't have many
chances yeah after basics i wasn't
planning to play c5 but i had i looked
at my club and i was down 50 minutes 50.
yeah i had 30 minutes and he had almost
an hour 20.
yeah i think he barely used any of his
time today like i was uh
yeah black of many moves like work
difficult even four seconds eight also
or rook is six right i thought rook e6
also makes sense but maybe that one
didn't want to calculate knight f4 right
and then well after this six i was gonna
play something else at first but then i
like eat three but then i look at my
time in the talking time too
time to bail out yeah time to play
bailout basically i i didn't fly away
consolidate because every time player ac
one has through k6 attacked my eight
pawn
so uh
yeah i'm not really sure
sometimes you just don't get chances
yeah you know like yeah you wanna get
chances okay again fabian i managed to
win an equal position
well you seem to outplay him from very
nicely in that one yeah thank you
i mean it was equal in the opening so
that's true yeah
wesley we got to ask you uh the drama
surrounding the tournament what are your
feelings now that magnus is not in it
yeah did they give an official reason no
no yeah yeah if everyone's been silent i
i guess uh
yeah the day we had a lot of
um
solid draws as well
i'm sure everyone's distracted like it
was hard for me to sleep last night
because of the
events here yeah because of the drama
and whether the weather whatever is
happening is true or not
um i remember six years ago 2016
all the top players were just preparing
on classical chess and classical chess
and all that but now we have online we
have rapid blitz and then we have all
this drama so it just
makes it a bit
difficult to concentrate
um and also i play han siemen on round
six
so uh
i don't know but with the increase
with advancement of technology these
days it's hard to predict already what's
uh
what's possible or what's not
i know online there's a lot of
cheating involved but over the world of
course it's much harder
but i'm not exactly tech savvy and and
all that i mean i can think of few ways
to
do it but not the most advanced person
so i guess only time will tell what was
happening the drama has affected your
sleep and now you're playing hans yeah
yeah i mean i was watching today and i
mean he probably get uh he probably gets
somebody and beat me in around six but
we'll see what happens um
but again only only time will tell you
know he'll play in the u.s championship
as well and
we still have no
idea what's happening or what's going on
but uh
i'm just saying the world does
definitely change compared to six years
ago you know everything's more advanced
these days but i'm trying i'm just
trying to play
some good chess you know i'm trying to
improve trying to focus on my classical
chess uh the last few months have been
i haven't really done anything special
so i'm just trying to i just gotta focus
on my own game i guess but uh
yeah it's um it's interesting i think
before tournament everyone expected
magnus to cruise through this tournament
um but now that he's gone the
tournament's wide open oh yeah i know he
was my pick to win the term right now
it's gone i mean i'm not very happy
about that yeah i mean
it's 100 points higher than everybody
else
that helps leslie thank you for your
time we know that you will need plenty
of prep for the rest of the tournament
yeah it's also nice that i get two rest
days now that is also very true are you
gonna be having more whites or blacks
no i'll have five blacks five blacks and
three wipes well i hope that you're the
leader of the tournament right now yeah
i'm white against magnus
only i can substitute it that is a pity
well wesley thanks for joining us here
in the studio and we'll go back to the
only game remaining
thank you uh alejandro in fact there is
one game remaining and a very exciting
game i like lanier's position very very
much